Clarissa
Jean-Philippe était né il y a 26
ans en martéique à Fort de France
elle avait grandi dans un quartier le
quartier de derrièreemne à Sainte-Marie
elle aimait son quartier
elle aimait son île elle aimait la
France elle voulait servir etcherch
comment se poser cette question
être
utile alors très jeune Clarissa
Jean-Philippe quitte la Martinique pour
la métropole
elle effectue sa formation à l'école de
police de pentin
elle y démontre très vite des
qualités pour devenir une excellente
policière municipale
elle est impatiente elle est rayonnante
elle est ardente elle a hâte de mettre
en pratique là où on lui dira d'aller
les connaissances qu'elle a acquises à
l'école
elle est recrouter à montrrouge ses
camarades sont là comme stagiaire
elle a réussi si bien qu'elle venait
d'être
titularisée au moment même où elle a été
assassinée sa responsabilité c'était
d'assurer la tranquillité publique de sa
ville
à la sortie des écoles sur les voies de
circulation au contact des jeunes des
familles des commerçants des
passants une policière
municipale qui avait à assurer la
sécurité de la voie publique et
notamment après un accident de la
circulation c'était jeudi Clarissa était
là
elle était lâchement atteinte dans le
dos par un projectile de gros calibre
tiré par son
agresseur comment
justifier que l'on puisse tuer
lâchement une jeune femme de 26 ans
riche de toutes les promesses de la vie
dévouer aux
autres
comment peut-on comprendre qu'un
assassin commette cette
abomination quel peut être le MOB d'e
telle
abjection posons-nous ces
questions tout
simplement tout
cruellement parce que Clarissa portait
un
uniforme qu'elle était
policière qu'elle était le symbole de la
République peut-être il y a-t-il même
une autre explication qui s'ajoute à
celle-là elle était là pour empêcher un
terroriste d'aller plus loin dans sa
folie vers cette école située à quelques
centaines de mètres qu'elle protégeit
par sa présence l'enquête le
dira c'est donc en martyre qu'est tombé
Clarissa Jean-Philippe jeudi dernier son
visage celui d'une jeune fille
ultramarine heureuse
de servir sa ville et son pays ce visage
là nous éclairera pour toujours